great I'd like to talk about crops and
temperature extremes and in particular
I'm going to do a more narrow view on
that and really talk about corn and heat
waves for the perspective of adaptation
whether or not we should expect heat
waves to get hotter and then medium term
forecasting of heat waves this is work
that I've done with Ethan Butler
Marinella and Karen McKinnon Nathan
Mueller and andy ryan's so here for
better or worse is how average yield of
corn in the US has changed since
nineteen sixty-five it's roughly doubled
but what I'm going to be talking about
is this variability around the trend and
here we have in this black line here the
D trended yield you can see that during
2012 which we've already heard about
when we had heat wave and drought we had
a reduction in total yields about twenty
percent less than usual we saw the same
thing in 1988 now what I've superimposed
on this black detrended yield curve is
an indication of high temperatures okay
this is really the cumulative sum of
temperatures above 30 degrees Celsius
day by day during the growing season
year by year and what you can see is
there's a good correspondence between
the two in fact this index of high
temperatures explains more than sixty
percent of the variance in the anomalies
in yield okay so you have a strong
coupling between temperature and
temperature also often involves moisture
availability and yield how many bushels
per hectare can be generated what people
have often done is to take the
sensitivity that can be diagnosed when
does this sort of analysis and say okay
well when we go into the future we have
a long-term warming how much loss of
yield are we going to have and that
makes some sense but it doesn't account
for the fact that we can adapt through
time and so if we want a more resolved
view of how changes in temperature might
influence food production we'd also want
some sort of measure of adaptation and
here in this more resolved plot is one
way of getting at that what I'm showing
here in color is sensitivity of yield to
changes in these hot temperatures
calling them killing degree days and you
can see there's a gradient going here
from the Northeast to the southwest
where you have lower sensitivities
now the contours are showing the
climatology of these killing degree days
how often it's really hot in a given
place and you can see that this too has
a gradient where we have obviously
hotter temperatures here towards the
south and somewhat to the west now this
extent patterns can be used to infer
what adaptation has been alright these
are the mean climate ologies and what
we're growing in these various places
and how we're doing it and you can use
this as a proxy then for the amount of
adaptation that we might be able to
expect going forward and if one does
that it has big consequences so taking a
simple scenario we say a mean warming of
2 degrees Celsius if we had no
adaptation we would infer fourteen
percent loss and yields but if we do
adapt according to our model fit here to
the spatial variability you only get a
four percent decline now I want to take
these numbers seriously but I would take
the fact that adaptation plays a big
role in the damages that you might
expect something that's quite robust and
something that should be accounted for
in any type of assessment of what's
likely to be the consequence of climate
change okay so that's point one now
briefly point2 let's look at how
temperatures actually have been changing
and this is over the last century and
particular date intervals chosen
according to one good census data is
available what we are looking at in
particular is the hottest temperatures
during the growing season this is the
95th percentile of temperature and what
we see is it's warming over most of the
US but here right in the midst of the
Corn Belt what we actually have is
cooling it's fairly substantial these
hottest temperatures have decreased on
average by about 2 degrees Celsius now
if we want to know how has changes in
our changes in temperature going to
influence production going into the
future we want to know of whether or not
these kind of fortuitous cooling pattern
in this particular location is likely to
persist for which we need a mechanism
we've assessed a number of different
possible mechanisms and the one that
really seems the most valuable is this
notion that through entry increased
agricultural intensity we actually have
greater capacity for evapotranspiration
in the Corn Belt okay particular was
happening on the very hottest days we're
seeing greater cool
because of evapotranspiration
evaporative cooling and the crops
themselves are changing the climate in a
way that is beneficial for growing crops
that's shown over here this metric of
agricultural intensity in terms of net
primary production so we move to the
right higher increases in that primary
product production and we can see this
change in hot temperatures getting
greater and greater cooling as we move
off to the right stars indicate
statistical significance okay so we
might expect that this pattern will
persist to some degree going forward in
so much as we have available water okay
and that's a big caveat a lot of
additional things to think about there
okay one final point okay we've also
been looking at can we predict heat
waves and this is on a timescale of
weeks and months now not centuries and
here's a typical pattern when we have a
heat wave during the growing season in
the eastern US the closed contour is
indicate high pressure which is a
company's high temperatures and it so
happens that when we have heat waves in
the eastern US they are typically
associated with a sea surface
temperature pattern that exists over in
the mid latitude Pacific this pattern is
one of a try pole where we have cool
warm cool now there's not an
instantaneous link between what's going
on here and here but if we go back five
days in an average sense relative to
when a heat wave occurs what we can see
is that these pressure anomalies exist
across this entire strip here where we
have negative pressure anomalies in the
dash positive negative positive and so
this is like a wave train we're actually
seeing in the red arrows is the activity
of waves propagating directly from the
mid-latitudes over the pacific over to
the eastern US aiding in the development
of this high-pressure that is associated
with the heat wave that eventually
occurs now it turns out to be quite nice
is if we look at the sea surface
temperature patterns they evolved
through time if we go back ten days we
have a situation where it's more of a
dipole in the north south and less of a
try pole in the east west as we go back
as much as 40 days we can see the
evolution of this pattern taking place
in a fairly consistent and predictable
fashion we can
use that as an index for predicting heat
waves and this would be the last thing
that I show you when applauding here is
an odds ratio and what it's showing is
that 40 days prior to a heat wave
depending on the expression of this
pattern in the mid-latitude Pacific we
can have odds of a heat wave that are
greater than twice climatology or if we
have the negative phase of this pattern
in the Pacific less than half of what is
typical for one standard deviations and
this pattern index now this is only 40
days that's not going to be quite early
enough to decide what you're going to
plant but we think through ocean
forecasting and other possibilities
maybe we can extend it even further such
that farmers would have more advance
notice of what's likely to occur that's
it thanks